foreign
[Music]
at last
today
our days of peace
begin
we thought our Joys would be an ending
we thought our light
would never dim
it's guys
strange
range
[Music]
the moment we feared
[Music]
evil does not sleep
it waits
Beyond The Darkness tempting Shadow to
barriers all beneath the mountain
[Music]
he has not
foreign
[Music]
each of us must decide who we shall be
[Applause]
foreign
oh
really
there was a time when the world was so
young
they had not yet been a sunrise
but even then
there was light
come to me
[Music]
elves have forests to protect
doors their minds
mend their fields of grain
but we our foods have each other
[Music]
we're safe
you have fought long enough
put up your sword
you're still out there the question now
is where
it is over you have not seen what I've
seen I have seen my share
you have not seen
what I have seen
Darkness will March over the face of the
Earth
it will be the end not just of our
people
but all because
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I am sorry but their time has come
the past is with us hope
the past is dead
we either move forward
or we die with it
this could be the beginning of a new era
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what else is out there
[Music]
there's wonders in this world beyond our
wandering
foreign
foreign
[Music]